ladies gentlemen welcome to this debate
Thank You Hana thank you intelligence
squared a sign that I moved from
television to radios I'm allowed to wear
a jumper now it feels like a
transformation the other aspect of
tonight which is interesting for me as a
presenter of the Today program is the
joke is on me I have to introduce a
series of people without interrupting
them for nine minutes which is going to
be living hell but I'm going to do my
best I just want to check that you're
all entitled to be here could you just
hold up a blue Passport there was no
comment the BBC has new views at all but
it was it was quite funny that it had to
be made in France wasn't it um now in
the tradition of all great debates we've
already rigged it learning from Vladimir
Putin so it's already been stuffed
already but we will you have had the
chance you have had the chance to have a
vote as you know and we're going to
bring you the result of that after we've
heard the opening speeches and then the
purpose of tonight is not just to hear
the arguments from both sides not just
to hear from you let me just stress when
I say hear from you nobody is actually
paid to come and hear you tonight so if
you've brought a speech can you put it
away because what we'd love to hear from
you is a pithy question a pithy
observation a contribution to debate but
not the speech you would have given if
only you've been invited to come here
we will hear from you after you've heard
the speeches and critically you will
then get the chance to vote again just
to be clear because it's highly
complicated and it's a deeply technical
solution that intelligence squared have
come up with a small piece of paper now
the clue is in the words for and against
so a simple thing later on when we come
to it I'll tell you if you've not made
your mind up you put the whole thing in
the box if you have made your mind up
tear it into and state the blindingly
obvious pop for in if you're for but
against in
if you're against and we will bring you
the final result and compare it with
what you've thought as you walked into
the room but what we want to do is hear
our speakers tonight instead of
introducing them all at the beginning
I'm going to introduce them one at a
time as they come up to speak
the first speaker you're going to hear
from tonight and each speakers got about
10 minutes they're welcome to take less
time if they want to we're going to hear
first of all from Chuck or Ramona now
Chuck Ramona as you know is the Labour
MP MP for straighter means the former
shadow business secretary and leads now
a cross-party coalition with around half
a million supporters who are calling for
what they call for what he calls are
people's votes on the final deal so
ladies in the of them please welcome
chuck Ramona
well good evening everyone and thank you
very much to intelligence squared for
asking me to speak this evening
I jumped straighten thanks for the
introduction that I've been called a
Ramona Ramona the last time I did one of
these events with Nigel Roger I was
called a Romanian and I'm proud I'm
proud to be all of those things because
this issue is more than political it is
about my family I'm a quarter Irish you
may not be able to see that from my
complexion I've got a Danish
brother-in-law a Danish niece and nephew
I have a French aunt we have Spanish
Nationals in my family some of my family
are here with me tonight and we are very
typical of so many families in my
constituency which are similarly British
and European and proud to be so my
constituency scored the highest remain
boat in the country in 2060 and we are
very proud of that you can clap if you
want and so we are part of that 16
million group of people who've been
smeared as some liberal metropolitan
elite you know those who voted against
brexit those citizens of nowhere well
let me tell you something about Stretton
we are proud to be metropolitan and
diverse with 40% of our community being
drawn from an ethnic minority background
we don't believe that immigrants whether
EU citizens or not are the cause of all
the problems in Lambeth and we are proud
to be liberal to pro-equality Pro Human
Rights Pro the liberal view of the world
but don't you dare call my constituents
some elite I am fed up hearing people
smear those who voted to remain in the
European Union as some elite most of our
residents in Lambeth can't afford to own
their own
home and rent one in fall of my
constituents lives in absolute poverty
we're one of the most deprived local
authority areas in England so no we are
not a community that has seen all of the
benefits of globalization and hasn't
seen the downside I've made a point as
chair of the All Party Parliamentary
Group on social integration we're
spending a lot of time in the
communities that voted in the opposite
way that voted in the greatest number to
leave like for example in Boston and
Skegness to understand what drove the
vote back in 2016 in those areas and you
know what I found
it was the same problems and the same
challenges that we face in Lambeth a
lack of decent and affordable homes not
enough well paid jobs that enable you to
provide for your family pressures on
public services that don't have enough
resources that's what I found and in
short as I said those were the same
challenges affecting my community that I
saw mirrored in those communities that
are often referred to as left behind
communities that voted to leave and
there are people there who has left
behind as people in my own community but
the difference is that we didn't believe
that brexit would solve all the problems
I've just outlined in fact our belief in
Lambeth was that it would exacerbate
them but that that was then and in some
senses I think people are fed up with
this whole brexit debate they wonder you
know why don't you just get on with this
thing why is it taking so long and the
truth is that in 2016 and I think
whether you're you know leave will
remain in this room
you weren't knowledge we were having a
hypothetical debate then about what
would happen if we voted to leave but
now we are actually dealing with the
reality of the situation we're dealing
with facts in a way that we weren't
dealing with them then we are in 2018
now and we've got to face the reality of
the actual situation
that we're in and I think there are a
number of things that we can all agree
on however you voted wherever you are in
our country this process is taking far
longer these negotiations than any of us
really thought they would take and they
are much much more complex than I think
many people foresaw I mean who would
have thought that brexit would have the
impact that it is clearly posing to the
Good Friday Agreement settlement in
Northern Ireland which bought peace
after so many decades of bloodshed he
would have thought brexit would impact
on that situation in the way that it
clearly is who would have thought that
brexit would impact on the
transportation of medical isotopes used
in cancer treatment and research and the
list goes on of all these things that
you never would have thought brexit
would impact on and clearly I think we
all now know we're not going to get the
economic benefits you have as a member
of the club outside of the club I mean
why would you join the club in the first
place if you could get all the benefits
without complying with the obligations
or paying the membership fees all that
nonsense that you know you were told you
know the Italians want to sell us
Prosecco the French breather German cars
and therefore we would get all these
wonderful special benefits of course we
will now know that is not the case and
what we do know is that we are going to
be paying a whopping great divorce bill
of up to 40 billion pounds no one
mentioned that before we're going to be
making payments through to twenty sixty
four so that we can exit and continue to
have some participation in some parts of
the European Union if we're lucky but of
course no say on any of those rules and
well do I need to mention the big red
bus you know and there's three
underwears that's 350 visits got over
350 million pounds extra per week for
your lectures we all know that's not
going to happen we do know that 10,000
medical professionals have left our NHS
since that leave vote and we've got
nursing shortages we know that we also
know that everyday items that we all
rely on bread cereal coffee tea those
types of things they're all a lot more
expensive because of the depreciation
of the pound sterling so for all those
reasons surprisingly or not I am still
of the view that we are far better off
in the European Union seeking to change
our country within that framework than
leaving it of course I would love to
stop brexit but in a way that the title
up here is kind of beside the point
because my argument is that whatever
happens given the gravity and the
magnitude of this issue and let's be
frank about this there's not going to be
a consensus in the House of Commons on
what we do on this deal when charissa
may returns from Brussels with it we
expect at the end of this year there's
not going to be consensus but given the
gravity of this I think it is wrong it's
just plain wrong
that 650 people should vote on this
brexit deal which will impact on every
single family in this room and many
generations to come and yet 65 million
people should be denied their say on the
deal and I'll tell you what above all I
just cannot get over the fact that we
will be denying so many young people
over half a million young people have
not had a say on this at all and when I
do visits in my constituency every
Friday now on my favorite things to do
is to visit my colleges and schools and
I speak to the young people who are so
energized by this debate and so many of
them feel that we the older generations
and I kind of accepted the FATA moving
maybe into that category relative to so
many of my younger considers but they
think we are denying them the benefits
that we've taken for granted for so long
during our membership of the European
Union whatever you think of that my view
is they deserve a say and actually I
think they should have a say from the
age of 16 I just want to wrap up by
saying this look democracy is not static
I know some people would like to think
that you press the button and everything
stops at a point in time but it isn't
static it is dynamic and that's why we
have regular general elections and we
have national polls and to those who
worry about the democratic element of
this I don't think you can thwart the
will of the people if they are the ones
get to determine the future trajectory
of this country in the end we're talking
about their futures I know which way I
would be voting if we have another poll
but for goodness sake let us make sure
that it's not an elite in Westminster
they determine our futures let's give
the people a vote on the brexit deal
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much Anita
Karuna now for the first speaker against
the motion brexit must be stopped
Isabella Oakshott currently writing a
book called white flag on the state of
the British Armed Forces former
political editor The Sunday Times author
of call me Dave you remember about the
pig okay and also the bad boys of brexit
is a black show your ten minutes starts
now
thank you rather better than the
reception I used to get sometimes when I
worked for the Daily Mail when sometimes
people would start hissing before I even
sat down I want to start with a bit of a
confession tonight I am a brexit here
and I am absolutely sick of brexit when
Tereza may arrived in Brussels today she
said she was looking forward to the
talks on brexit and I honestly think
this has to be [ __ ] does anyone look
forward to talking about Breck's at
these days except perhaps us tonight
when we're clearly going to have a very
lively debate I think that the whole
nation including those of us who
passionately feel that brexit must go
ahead in the form that people thought
they were voting for I think people are
fed up of it they just want to get on
with it so that we can get on in doing
and tackling some of the other stuff
that chucker listed the important issues
like defence health and education care
for the elderly none of which are
frankly whatever the government tells
you right now
none of them are getting the bandwidth
that they deserve casting my mind back
to the referendum which just feels like
a lifetime away that was one of the most
exciting nights if not the most exciting
night of my professional life as a
Euroskeptic journalist I really come to
know a lot of the key players on the
campaign's over the years
and on the night of the referendum I was
with many of the key figures on those
teams including with Nigel Farage and
the levy you team and I'll never forget
what a kind of extraordinary roller
coaster that was but particularly for
those politicians that have devoted so
much of their lives to the fight to
getting out of the EU and I remember for
the rest of my life standing on college
green very early on the morning after
the referendum and the Sun was just
coming up and there was such a sense of
jubilation amongst all of those who
voted for brexit and disbelief that this
had actually happened and I remember the
lorries were trundling past the House of
Commons and honking on their horns and
what I'd like to think was jubilation -
it was really exciting around that time
we as a family bought a little puppy and
it was a little cocker spaniel and I got
a little bit carried away and I had this
idea that perhaps we should call him
brexit luckily I was overruled by the
kids on that one who realized that the
poor thing was going to have a bit of an
image problem especially in the place
where we live which is a little town in
what was David Cameron's constituency
which is a kind of pocket of remainer
resistance in fact chil Barry still has
you flags all over town to the point
that I've almost thought about putting
up one on our house just so that I don't
become too much of a social pariah
anyway I'm glad that we didn't call the
dog brexit because since then the whole
breaks that thing has gone downhill a
bit we have developed a bit of an image
problem and you know we've learned all
sorts of awful things about brexit and
brexit is to a ridiculous degree I mean
did you know for example that brexit
ears aren't very good at brushing their
teeth they're not even very good at
changing their pants apparently I'm not
making this up this is verifiable YouGov
research anyway I'm getting a bit
distracted by what a what a misery it's
all been and actually the message is
much more positive than that but I want
to
my last few minutes to try to tackle
some brexit myths what does this debate
here tonight all about it's about one
thing
democracy that's pretty much it people
have voted it was a yes or no question
first-past-the-post yes it was close but
the result was clear seventeen point
four million people voted for out that's
the biggest mandate in history in fact
it's the biggest vote in British history
on anything and there was a huge turnout
so politicians can like it or not but
it's their democratic duty now to carry
it out and can you imagine how
disastrous it would be for democracy if
a bunch of politicians decided that
actually they don't like the result and
so they're going to ask us all again in
fact ideally framing the question so
they can only really be one answer the
one that they want what if we went
through all this again and as seems very
likely the result was just as narrow as
it was last time then what would have
been achieved so for me this is the most
important point tonight it is about
democracy this was not supposed to be
the best of three now while we're on the
point about democracy I want to just
make sure you don't fall for a classic
piece of remainer trickery that true
democracy would be about having a second
referendum you can see that you use
contempt for democracy purely in its
approach to referenda actually I mean
we've been here before they've got two
tactics basically you threaten the
country with economic economic
retaliation and then force it to hold a
second referendum that's what happened
to Ireland when it voted against the
Lisbon Treaty back in 2007 or and this
is a real danger they accept the vote
and then just do what the voters
rejected anyway but in another guise and
that's what happened to the French and
the Danes when they voted against the
European Constitution in 2005
anyway I mean it's important to note by
the way that jean-claude Juncker has
been pretty open about his contempt for
democracy here's a selection of his best
quotes
if it's a yes we'll say on we go if it's
a no we'll say we continue here's
another one
Britain is different of course there
will be transfers of sovereignty but
would I be intelligent to draw attention
to this fact here's another one monetary
policy is a serious issue we should
discuss this in secret I'm ready to be
insulted as being insufficiently
democratic but I want to be serious I am
for secret dark debates and finally and
here's the thumper there can be no
democratic choice
against the European treaties he
actually said that so onto other myths
classic ones people who voted for brexit
have changed their minds now they've
realised how awful it's going to be look
this is just rubbish there is no
evidence that people have changed their
mind there have been a few polls which
appear to show a sliver of difference
now in favor of remain how do we know
that's not to be taken with any great
significance well the analysis is that
that little difference there is all down
to people who actually didn't vote last
time they didn't even bother voting last
time and might vote this time and if
they did they might vote remain it is
not to be taken seriously then there's
the classic one about you know this vote
doesn't count because brexit is lied bla
bla bla 350 million bla bla bla of
course we could expect that to come up
tonight and this suggestion that people
didn't really know what they were voting
for I think this is absolutely insulting
I think people knew exactly what they
were voting for now it may have been an
emotional vote rather than one based on
economic my new tie but that's no less
valid for that and I'm not even going to
bother with the remain lies because I
think we're all pretty much equal on
that the other myth is that brexit is
some kind of aberration the result of a
one-off vote a kind of historic accident
let's go through all the votes that led
to brexit and I'll do this really
quickly
of all a governing party the
Conservatives won a majority in an
election with a manifesto that promised
a referendum secondly Parliament voted
through the legislation guaranteeing the
referendum thirdly the referendum
actually took place fourthly Parliament
voted to pass article 53 the
Conservatives were returns to government
in 2017 on a promise to implement brexit
and in fact the party that promised to
reverse it the Lib Dems did pretty crap
then we have Theresa maid becoming Tory
leader on a promise to implement brexit
in full and Jeremy Corbyn who beat Owen
Smith and that's Owen Smith who wanted
to reverse brexit so it's perfectly
clear voters have had plenty of chance
to elect anti brexit candidates and
they've rejected them and finally if
you're still feeling nostalgic about the
EU just look at John Claude yonkers
sickening letter to Putin congratulating
him on his re-election this man wants to
be mates with a murderer a murderer who
as we've seen holds democracy in utter
contempt that is not something we should
do ourselves by stopping brexit if ever
there was a reason to strike out into
the world on our own that's it thank you
thank you very much indeed Isabella
shots next to speak for the motion
brexit must be stopped
geena milho you will know Gina for lili
leading the legal battle for a
parliamentary vote
[Applause]
she is
just before genus - is founder of SCM
direct an investment company and
confessed just before which her husband
raised an eyebrow - that she is known in
the city as the Black Widow spawn IDO
so Gina Miller please speak Thank You
Nick good evening everyone and thank you
to the organizers for inviting me
tonight I want to get down to a serious
talk just a year ago just over a year
ago the Supreme Court in the decision my
case force the government to behave
lawfully and have invoked the triggered
us leaving the European Union 40 months
on I think we are all entitled to
question exactly what our government has
achieved on Monday to much fanfare the
draft transitional agreement was
published it contains we saw quite a lot
of green a large amount of agreed detail
importantly however this draft agreement
or green with the will see signing
tomorrow almost by default shines a
light on the significant amount that is
still to be agreed there is still a
mountain of uncertainty there is still
no sector-by-sector
substance there has been no agreement on
the primacy of the ECJ during transition
period there has been no agreement on
data sharing for collective and mutual
security purposes there has been nothing
decided on fisheries or Northern Ireland
to which as we know has got the brexit
ears on media maneuvers and up in arms
the government are putting a brave face
on what their way there achieved or they
have achieved but as we know the brexit
ears are not happy they are saying that
they will vote down the agreement and
then a sort of perverse vindication
surely that means it's actually going in
the right direction
but anyway on a more serious note the
brexit ears have also said that they
want to set the bar even higher that the
things they want in my view are complete
Clee irreconcilable with anything that
would be an oddly brexit they appear to
be holding a very destructive and
disloyal pistol to missus Mays head
they've set the bar as I've said
impossibly high and they talk about us
being traitors it is therefore possible
to conclude that far from resolving
things and setting a steady cause for
the next round of negotiations the
agreement this week will achieve
precisely the opposite namely increased
risk facing the brexit negotiations
because the gap between the government
and the right bring sort of extreme
brexit ears in the parliamentary
conservative party seems to be wider
than ever and the ability to close that
gap looks as though it's impossible for
two reasons one is the amount of time we
have left
do not be tricked into thinking we have
till December 2020 we have till the end
of October this year seven months also
because there are these incredibly
unrealistic demands as I've said they
almost want to sort of remove an egg
from an omelet or someone put it the
other day so we're here we find
ourselves not really where we thought we
would be and actually I think most
brexit ears should be upset and angry
because they're not being delivered the
brexit they were promised but the
remainders perhaps we'll have a little
lighter tread in their step in the
thinking that maybe the negotiation
going better I'm not sure about that as
I said because of the time restraints
and the complexities and the red lines
the outcome may awell may well be a
plague on all our houses however you
voted so if this is a gross betrayal a
denial of fundamental flaw what is the
answer I think the answer lies in our
democratic accountability
democratic accountability transparency
and openness the things we cherish
apparently on both sides there is no
divide there we both treasure
sovereignty democracy honesty truth so
why not have that to my mind let's have
some honest talking because we've not
really talked about the rumours
emmaandemma nating from the UK and
French ports authorities that we hear
that there could be thirty mile queues
at the borders between Dover and Calais
on both sides of the channel and a run
on perishable foods medical supplies
basic household goods have we heard that
well actually the holiest associations
the transport associations are all
saying it but it's not being reported
similarly we're hearing nothing about
the fact that if airlines do not have
50.1% EU citizen ownership they may well
not be able to fly on the 1st of January
2021 that is be a easyJet Ryanair so
what does this mean what does this all
mean to me to my mind the risks are
increasing not decreasing as we go
through these negotiations it is not
good enough to say there's no problem
it'll all be sorted out it is not good
enough for the government to say all is
well and there will be some sunlit
uplands as we walk forth hand-in-hand
they are not in some all's well that
ends well play about deceit and
self-deception
this is actually about the kind of
behavior that we want in our country and
as isabella quite rightly say that we
would call out in the kremlin and other
deceitful governments but we are not
calling out in our own government i am
told by both the EU and UK side
that there is potential for chaos
because the government seems totally
unwilling to acknowledge or provide
credible reassurances or plans that
people are completely baffled
so I have come to the point that the
breakfast tears are saying that they're
not happy they'll think make things more
difficult it is my view that the public
must have the right to vote on whether
they think the outcome of the
negotiations is good enough and is
consistent with the vision they were
promised in 2016 if you're a company you
do a regular audit to check if your
strategy is actually delivering on your
profit margins to what you promise your
consumers to what you promised your
staff well why can't we do that with our
country the approach should be the same
I am firmly of the view that the public
should have the right to vote on the
real and tangible results of the
negotiations and I cannot see what is so
unfair about that in fact it is not
unfair is it not the most democratic
thing to do it holds true to the
enduring values of our liberal and
representative democracy by
demonstrating real accountability to
voters even Jacob Riis MOG in 2011 said
if this doesn't go well there should be
a second vote the issue therefore isn't
why would we have a people's vote on the
future of our country but why wouldn't
we if the role is to stop breaks it in
that vote then we would accept that but
we are not there yet a people's vote on
the options on their future on the
future of the country and what they want
is surely the most democratic thing we
can do to end this because I think all
of us on this panel will agree there is
no space there is no bandwidth for the
domestic causes of brexit there is no
time being spent
on policing housing NHS we all agree on
that we are fed up with brexit but there
must be a vote that draws a line is
respected whichever way it is and we
have to get on with our country and
bringing our people back together again
thank you
thank you - Gina - the the last speaker
in our debate tonight speak against the
motion breath it must be stopped as
Gerald Lyons used to be chief economic
adviser to the mayor of London when it
was Boris Johnson is the co-author of a
book called clean brexit why leaving the
EU still makes sense and he is chief
economic strategists at the
discretionary wealth manager net wealth
investments Gerald Lyons
well good evening thank you to the
organizers for inviting me it's great
honor to be on the panel with the other
speakers elections come and go people
often vote by habit but when it comes to
referendums you are really really really
forced to think and in the first half of
2016
people thought I have three I have three
children they were then 18 22 24 they
told me for four months they and their
friends talked about one thing
the referendum tonight I think we should
embrace the result and actually respect
the result and talking out bringing our
country together who thinks a second
referendum an acrimonious four-month
referendum is going to bring this
country together in fact I think people
instead of trying to have another
referendum should actually get behind
the government and force it to be
arguing in Britain's best interests
received Arman and focus on three areas
why economically we should embrace
brexit second why I think young people
are those who should be most optimistic
about brexit and third why gosh imagine
if they were right what would happen
dear me first the economy Britain has a
really
imbalanced economy it has fundamental
problems we need to address up to and it
has some fundamental strengths these
were highlighted by the global financial
crisis a decade ago and after 40 odd
years been in the EU we haven't really
addressed some of these issues but I
think with brexit we have a fundamental
positive opportunity the world economy
is changing globalization technical
change innovation the fourth Industrial
Revolution are positive for an economy
like Britain which has 80 percent
services if we can position ourselves
globally being in the EU indeed if we
went back into it would be like walking
the wrong way on an escalator
controlling centralizing regulating we
need to break free of that and the
referendum has given us an opportunity
people vote for all sorts of reasons
sovereignty migration and the economy
was shown to be
the three big factors and that's why we
are where we are we have to be outside
the single market outside the single
market rest respect sovereignty coming
back to Parliament we set our own laws
you the people keep the MPs to account
outside the single market allows us to
have our own migration policy not the
current migration policy based on
geography we discriminate against the
rest of the world we favor the EU but a
migration policy based on skills and
what we need low migration does not mean
no migration also at the same time it
allows us to focus our economy let's
look at some of the facts the EU is a
declining share of the world economy the
EU is a declining share of our exports
indeed back in 1980 the current EU would
have been 34% of the globe economy now
it's 22% after we've left it's going to
be less than 20% still important hence
we need to have a good relationship with
it but not the most important thing even
the European Commission let's give them
the benefit of the doubt
they say 85% of global growth in the
next two decades will come from outside
the European Union on top of that how
many of our firms actually sell into
this single market which used to be
called the internal market how many
eight percent tax revenue tell you it's
only five percent I go on the wider
figure eight percent 92 percent of our
firms do not sell into the single market
they're controlled by the regulations of
the single market outside those eight
percent firms big multinationals can
still access the single market we have
to be outside the customs union its
discriminating I used to work it in the
city
I used to go across Africa it's owned
the chartered number of exporters you in
Africa connect their goods into the EU
market why think of it like this around
the customs union is a protective
barrier tariffs the terrace was set
there to protect French farmers German
car makers that's why in the other areas
tariffs have come down but basically the
highest tariffs we pay our on food
clothing footwear and autos we can then
set our own trade deals
several much smaller economies than the
British Chile Singapore Singh South
Korea with far less diplomatic and
commercial clout than we have have more
trade deals than the European Union
despite it being 28 countries
economically this is an opportunity
outside second young people I think
should embrace Breck's it's one of the
big myths is that they have most to fear
why would they shouldn't they be worried
out the growth of extremist parties
across all of Europe apart from in
Britain why is that happening because
it's built on shaky foundations why is
it that so many young people are
unemployed across Europe particularly in
southern European states because it's
built on unfit foundations basically
it's a discriminating setup it favors
big business that's why Jeremy Corbyn is
against it quite rightly what's
interesting and my son actually showed
me this 2012 the Home Office produced a
concept comprehensive report showing
where British people emigrate to what's
amazing young people say they can't
travel they won't be able to work in the
EU but the reality is very few of them
actually leave Britain to go and work in
the EU the data home office data shows
that when British people leave Britain
to retire they go to the EU when British
people leave Britain to go for work they
go outside the EU five of the top eight
countries where British people get jobs
when they leave Britain are outside the
EU North America Canada Australia New
Zealand you know it basically retire go
to the EU go for work elsewhere
basically younger people should
recognize that the longer further ahead
you look the more Britain will be able
to reposition itself globally outside
the EU democratic accountability global
approach these are things that young
people favor when Parliament is
answerable solely to the British people
and set laws based from the British
people rather than what bureaucrats and
others in Brussels say that will enhance
our democratic accountability third
imagine if we went back in
well autocratic leaders across the real
world ji Jing ping Putin in Turkey look
at Britain seventeen point four million
people vote and they disregard it gosh
what moral authority does that give us
then none basically we have to recognize
that we view the EU through an economic
and financial lens and the rest of the
EU views it through a political lens and
indeed we seem to forget the Amsterdam
treaty the Lisbon Treaty has happened
life has changed this is not the 1990s
this is an EU project that President
macron has outlined quite clearly in the
last six months he's highlighted the
reality we need to face up to he said
either the EU fragments into different
layers of core and the periphery or it
marches on - closer political union the
reality is that if we go back in we
either have a choice of been in the
periphery where we have no control no se
or we have to sign up to a core to a
political union it's fundamentally
flawed it's based on the euro the
Germans and the French have made clear
survival of the euro is central to the
process the euro is the worst idea
thought up by anyone anytime anywhere
and it's central to the EU let me
let me let me conclude not all has gone
well in the last 20 months I'm not here
to defend the government at all indeed
the complexity of leaving if you ask me
highlights why we must leave it shows
how much the EU has infiltrated every
aspect of our life sometimes without us
even knowing or realizing it basically
what's happened since the referendum on
the positive Google and all the tech
companies
despite grexit have decided that the UK
led by London will be their tech centre
outside of Silicon Valley there's been a
sea change in the city where I worked
for 25 years London is going to remain
the financial center of Europe the lady
okay well we can talk about this in the
Q&A at shell went down to the Labor
Party conference and it's going to
remain the financial center globally I
don't know what that was the funny point
genous said that we're going to have
queues at the border sometimes people
are very selective with their
information seven times the head of the
HMRC has testified to various
parliamentary committees they roll out
the new thing this summer he said they
will be working fully from day one
project fear now I didn't agree with
what went on the side of the bus I
wasn't involved in the official campaign
it was a gross finger bation have used a
net figure but the gist of it was we
send the vast amount of money and let's
fund our priorities instead that was a
message most people understood but if
you want to know what was the big
misinformation I went across the country
and the biggest misinformation was
project fear we were told in a year of
leaving five hundred
sorry in a year of a vote to leave never
mind leaving so by last June
five hundred thousand jobs would have
gone the worst case scenario was 800,000
jobs would have gone what's happened
we've added five hundred and fifty
thousand jobs basically there's lots of
things we should have done when we were
in the EU that we will now have to do
now and we can't blame Brussels but the
previous coalition government are the
whole series of competency reports and
these highlight why it's so complicated
to leave that those competency reports
shows that so many things we need to run
ourselves are currently run by Brussels
thank you
okay
for excellent speech is an opportunity
now for some debates for some questions
for some answers just to stress again
there is no a time for more speeches
there's no desire for more speeches now
there are microphones around I'm going
to point to people in order to get them
there's a microphone there you've got
one number two there I'd like to direct
my talk to Isabel you know who refers to
half the audience here as sniveling
liberals your sniveling liberals
apparently her Daily Mail diet the days
have not left her and she did her talk
about puppy and blah you know a pretty
rotten talk quite honestly and your
question is my question is I could go on
my question is when I was a school yep I
was really envious of follow school
children who had dual nationality you
know and I used to talk to them about it
some of them were even filing will and
they said oh yeah if tough things are
tough raelia question sir please well
the question is Isabelle and and this
group are trying to take away the
membership of the 27 nations that I had
a chart I caught up with these guys and
overtook them and you are taking that
away from me I want to know what right
you have to take it away from me right
thank you very much all right I've got
to take away your UK membership in
retaliation thank you very much for your
question forgive me I'm not in any sense
we need to be rude to you or anybody
else we have 20 minutes we want to whiz
through just before we get an answer to
that I was meant to tell you and forgive
me for forgetting this is how you voted
before and frankly you may have guessed
this from the reaction to speakers but
before the debate before hearing the
arguments afresh in favor of the motion
that brexit should be stopped 65%
against the motion
23% undecided 12% and we are going to
give you the chance to vote again
possibly to change your mind if you wish
to all to confirm your V so the
gentleman's question is about very
quickly what right have you got to take
away they benefit he had which is
sharing language and other skills with
27 other nations well first of all let
me tackle heads or
your suggestion that I'm saying
something against livering liberals I'm
confused by this in fact actually in the
run-up to the last election we had a Lib
Dem poster in our window I had to make
sure that it was neutralized by a Tory
one on your point about what right so I
have I have no right whatsoever sir this
is not about me taking away anybody's
membership of the 27 this is about the
the vote that took place and all
seventeen point four million people that
majority of people who voted for braixen
nothing to do with me right put number
two thank you very much it's a it's a
bit galling to hear Gina and Chaka
evoking democracy I don't remember you
campaigning for the right of the British
people to have a say on this including
millions of labour voters in the first
place if there had been 52 percent
remain you would not be campaigning for
a referendum now but the second point is
also that you you are waging a shameless
neo McCarthyite campaign whereby you
have insinuated that to be pro-european
as to be pro-eu I'm a European I'm half
French 1/4 Italian the vote leave
campaign was led by a Labour German NP
Giesler Stuart there are millions of
people across Europe who want a
different type of Europe than the
undemocratic system of government based
upon an unelected Commission which has
the monopoly right to introduce new
legislation
French people don't want that thank you
very much indeed
we'll get I will split the points of the
way chucko deal with the democracy point
the point being you're only in favor of
democracy if it took overturns
the result that you don't like you
weren't much interested in it before
well we have general elections every
four to five years and I'm not against
general elections because it might
change a government and I still I mean I
see where you're coming from but I still
can't see how you fought the will of the
people if they are the ones who in the
end determine what happens on this do
and I tell you the biggest fan of brexit
is that famous Democrat Vladimir Putin I
think that said something you know and I
don't get this McCarthyite thing I mean
we weren't McCarthyite at all about it
but I tell you where I do agree with you
millions do want change there's no doubt
about it the question is how you change
now I happen to think we've got a better
chance of changing all the problems
we've been talking about from within the
European Union working with lots of
other countries
across borders to try and get
globalization to work better for middle
and lower income a Gretchen bull I don't
see how you're gonna do that on your own
when you're living in the context of
globalization Gina can you address the
point that's being made which is there
is a blurring I think this is your point
sir a blurring between being
pro-european
and pro-eu and you can be anti deu and
perfectly positive about Europe and
indeed regard yourself as a European
it's not binary I mean you could be
British and European as well I mean it
works both sides of the argument so I
mean I think what I would say is that I
agree with you that what we're seeing at
the moment is a unity of the 27 when it
comes to brexit but beyond that there is
actually this unity and there are
problems in the EU and I would agree
that I think we have always been a very
strong voice we have been the people
writing most of the legislation and
brokering peace between the other member
states and we could be there reforming
from within
we just haven't that we don't have the
opportunity we're going to give away the
opportunity because unfortunately brexit
or fortunately whichever way you look at
it breaks it has actually been a heart
attack to the EU they are in shock and
there is a window of opportunity
especially with the reenergized
franco-german engine to create change
they are actually talking about it and
we should be there benefiting from it we
will not be with their benefit for it
relief thank you very much indeed I am
going to gonna take another point I'll
bring in Gerald in a moment those of you
with the microbes can you be a little
bit aware that men tend to put their
hands up more than women so if you are a
woman whereas oh there is over there
right number two have you got a woman
with the microphone now yes let's hear
thank you very much I'll just bring you
back in two SEC's Isabelle said that we
must deliver the brexit that the people
who voted for Bret said voted for how
does she actually know what that was how
did you
public just if you don't mind Isabel
because we're not heard from Gerald yet
in these questions how would you address
that point Gerald can I come back to the
previous people you know what Internet
so in terms of how people voted yet no
her point is she wants to know how on
earth you know what the will of the
people really is
well people as I said people vote for
all sorts of reasons but what we do know
is that from the work done are at the
time and afterwards that people voted it
seems in order
sovereignty was the most important issue
migrations second and economic factors
the third well you might include that in
migration of the economy I don't know
but in in so what's interesting just as
a few months ago that we heard that
youth quake no longer didn't actually
occur the other sees doing research that
shows that there's this myth that has
been broken about what type of people
voted for
brett-brett seeds it was across the
spectrum in fact it was what's
interesting it was across the political
spectrum as well in terms of two out of
three Tory voters I think about 30
percent of Labor voters or something
like that even more maybe up north
indeed which is partly explains why the
labor is so enthusiastic maybe about
leaving the single market as well so we
earn answer that question we know it
from research that's be done can I come
back to the previous point where it's
imported briefs no it's important
because Chuck and may the point and
you're Klatt about reforming where have
you actually be where have you actually
been I used to be on the advisory board
of open Europe which was Pro reformed
the EU think-tank and for ages the
biggest issue was reform the single
market in services and the single market
does not work in services and that
reform has been argued for by us the
Swedes everyone has it taken place no
okay you seem to forget why we had a
referendum David Cameron then Prime
Minister went and asked the EU to make
simple reforms and they say up yours
no mrs. Merkel said to Cameron you
should make this a remain and reform
agenda and he ignored her so you quite
like the idea the Germans tell us how to
run our sovereignty excuse me Mario
number three here's us together of
course it's all of us together yeah the
other back a point to Gina mellow first
of all my congratulations
congratulations and utmost admiration
you are the definition of democracy in
action thank you
the second point is to ask has a legal
pathway to a second referendum being
identified is a second referendum
actually a possibility in law okay thank
you very much addy Jeana there are
actually two ways we believe or a couple
of ways in the withdrawal bill
unfortunately it was missed in the House
of Commons but there is actually under
the 2011 Act if there is a treaty change
which are sleeping or the end deal will
be a treaty change you actually have to
by law have a referendum that will it is
now in the House of Lords and Lord
Adonis has laid down an amendment to
have that withdrawn if he is successful
it pings back to the House of Commons
and they say that that 2011 act cannot
be repealed because it was put in to
safeguard treaty changes for very good
reasons then that will naturally require
a referendum on the treaty thought
forgive me I thought this was a piece of
coalition legislation wasn't it and my
memory of that was because it's a
Liberal Democrats supporting it that
they basically said there would be a
referendum in the event of more powers
being transferred to Brussels now this
would not it technically is but the
thing is if it's a vassal state if we
end up in transition and then it would
be actually transfer and the second
point is that if in the meaningful vote
debate in Parliament there is a
requirement that the MPs say that there
needs to be a vote put back to the
people then that will be the mechanism
under which it's done thank you very
much yeah lady they're out there number
one
yep hello on you go this is a question
for chicka in view of the recent
revelations from Cambridge analytic ah
that elections are won on hopes and
fears rather than facts and debate what
are the implications for a second
referendum very briefly if you would
first of all I would like to know the
extent okay - which Cambridge analytic
er was involved with the leave campaigns
we need to know
the answer to that question and I
believe actually there will be more
revelations on that front in the coming
days I think secondly look III believe
the debate about our future of our
country has to be based as much as we
possibly can base it on evidence but I
also do think there is an emotional
argument to be made here as well and for
me at the heart of that has to be the
opportunities that we are providing for
the future generation in what we are
doing here but also there is a sense
somehow that we can blame the European
Union and the so-called bureaucrats I
mean never mind that it's elected heads
of government on an EU council who
determined things that happen in the
European Union with an elected European
Parliament as opposed to a European
Commission but the bottom line is I I
worry because I think one of the things
about 2016 referendum unleashed was this
sense that it's okay to other people and
blame other institutions for
domestically created problems okay and I
prefer to be hopeful and optimistic
about our capacity as a country to
address those problematic together yeah
this one's for mrs. Oakshott you stated
that there that we knew what we were
getting into with the vote but how could
we know when the day after the roses
result becomes known to the public
one of the most googled searches if not
the most because social is what is
brexit and how could we possibly know
what in reality we were getting into
when we would lied to so our educated
guess or our educated vote was false and
do you not believe that you stated that
we as a democracy should have the right
to vote but we are a representative
democracy and what we have voted for is
for our politicians to make an educated
guess on our behalf ok to your question
is a relation I mean the answer is
actually we couldn't possibly know the
detail of how it was going to pan out
but what we could know is what we were
seeking to regain which was sovereignty
and control over immigration as the two
key things that people voted for and you
know today actually Tucker brought up
this point about how the referendum was
a sort of hypothetical debate because we
weren't sure what was going to happen
well I mean of course we weren't
precisely sure what was going to happen
just like people weren't precisely sure
what would happen when they voted for
you to be their MP now fortunately they
weren't disappointed but you wouldn't
want another election before you've even
had a chance to start the job would you
but you regret saying that's what you
refer to as the lies were bla bla bla
first of all I don't for a minute except
that what went on the sides of the boss
actually was a lie because it said it
did not contain a pledge to do that so
I'm absolutely happy to stand by what
was on that bus really well I didn't put
it on my butt but Gerald Lyons you don't
think that what was on the bus was true
because it said the words 350 million
pounds a week are sent to Brussels
I think I'm accurate and saying there's
not been a single week in history in
which 350 million pounds has been sent
to Brussels oh well actually I said that
the week it was a big issue on the radio
for today program so I said I agree but
I think it's 350 on the side of us but
actually the biggest lie was the whole
information booklet that came out from
the government beforehand the biggest
lie and the biggest when I spoke across
the country at different events I wasn't
part of the official campaign I spoke at
lots of events the single biggest figure
that get got quoted was the 500 thousand
job losses the number of times people
said I would vote to leave but I'm
worried about losing my job they didn't
lose their job you know I just want to
put to you do you really believe that
there will not be medical supplies after
brexit and that there'll be 13 mile
queues at customs really well if you
I've spoken the people I've spoken to
but that detail comes from is the
freight haulage Association the UK
Transport Association the European
Transport Association as a possibility
no they are very worried because they
are going to be in as much trouble as we
are because we're talking about things
like on the medical point of view is
that if there is a delay of even six
minutes and it's HIV treat real drugs
they have to now design completely new
refrigeration systems there's going to
be delays there is only in Dover enough
room for 82 lorries we have no
compulsory buying orders going through
there is no substance in detail there is
nothing happening at the moment just as
I took Isabella but I'm just gonna be
gentle and you said it was never
reported except I did the Today
programme hi from Calais in which we
interviewed all the people who made the
point you just made
yeah could we have the microphone
over there please thank you very much
yes we've been talking quite a lot about
democracy but we've been focused on this
country I've just got back from Hungary
with there's Poland as well where
democracy is really under threat and
that threat is being ignored or
potentially upheld by the fact that
these leaders are not being disciplined
in any way by the EU in fact they're
being upheld so the idea of so how would
those who support the EU and those who
are not in favor of EU what's their
reaction to the way the EU is affecting
democracy if I may because I want to
stick it to the subject of the vote
about stopping brexit and whether that's
the right thing it seems to me the point
you're making is about democracy and let
me just pursue that with you chucker a
powerful point I thought was made in the
speeches there by Gerard which is the
people who will be pleased if you
overturn a democracy a democratic vote
of Vladimir Putin and President Xi
because it will give them the excuse to
ignore any vote that they want to ignore
in the future but the point is is
ultimately I can't stop brexit Jena
can't stop brexit ultimately it is the
people who have to make that
determination and there's a very big
difference from giving people a vote on
the deal and what we saw happen in
Russia over the weekend where the main
opposition figure was barred from
standing where election officials were
filmed stuffing ballot boxes and where
the media is rigged in favor of one side
of the argument if we actually had a
people's vote we would do things very
differently in this country and as I've
said there is a you know think about it
why is blad amir Putin and Donald Trump
for that matter they are the biggest
fans of BRICS it tells you something
about it not forever graduation sir yeah
evening I'd like to challenge mr. Lyons
who used to work in the city I do work
in the city and the mood there is not
good and I'd like to throw some numbers
at you over the 44 years Spira for
membership of the EU in 1973 UK GDP was
one hundred and ninety two and a half
billion dollars if we assume generously
an average annual growth rate of two
percent that 192 billion dollars would
be worth six hundred billion dollars GDP
today actually UK GDP is a shade under
three trillion dollars so clearly
something has been very beneficial over
that forty four year period how can you
stand there and tell us you're a
champion of free trade and yet challenge
our membership of the very institution
that has brought about such economic
growth okay thank you share our lives
well I could repeat why I say look I'm
still involved in the city I'm of the
board of Bank of China in the UK I meant
at net wealth investments I'm in the
advisory financial consultancy in the
city so I am still heavily involved in
the city hold on son I'm involved in the
city I was on the board of Joe city UK
so I speak to people in the state I was
at at lunch today with Nicky Morgan
we're sorry Jared no no the potato of
the question again let's just get to the
nub of the questions not about the city
let me just put it to you know brother
question is if I could put it on behalf
of the gentleman he's crudely if you're
in favor of free trade why would you
leave the largest free trade area in the
world a single map the customs union is
a protectionist Union it has a tariff
barrier around it that's why we have
high tariffs on food clothing footwear
and autos 8% of firms sell directly into
the single market they are the firms who
sell into the single market who could
still access it from outside it would be
wrong to attribute the success that
we've had and it's been very imbalanced
over the last 40 years to membership of
the EU we have a supply-side revolution
in the 1980s people seem to have
forgotten under mrs. Thatcher and then
subsequently under Tony Blair we had
phenomenal economic change in
transformation and it highlights the
fact that we need to actually be
thinking globally 85 percent of trade is
outside the EU sorry of 85 percent of
future growth will be outside the EU
according to the European Commission
okay thank you very much well we need to
reposition ourselves I'm sorry to go
over there it's only because I want to
get lots of points it okay there's a
number let's just see where all the
microphones are there's nothing let's
take a few in a row so we would take
number two because I know everybody
likes to have a chance number two number
four at the back there I'm sold
but the referendum was advisory because
no one knew what deals would get and
what deals when to go see
of course we were told that the EU would
pay us money but we have to pay 40
billion dollar pounds
we were told we're going to get the best
deals across the world
and yet we know that the easiest deal to
do will be six to seven years so I'd
like to ask the panel yeah why are they
not insisting on a lot of people's vote
why they know insist on people's I would
say that in a second yep where's number
four gone hello thanks so much brokered
and told I'd be interested to hear from
the brexit ears what life looks like
after we leave the EU for example in
sub-saharan Africa how are we going to
capture the eighty-five percent growth
you know there's a hundred you know 1
billion people in China how are we going
to capture that market it seems there's
a lot of talk about the Commonwealth as
it were I'm sure the Commonwealth
doesn't feel the same way so it'd be
interesting to understand how we try and
capture that market sure thank you it
number one yes my question is for Isabel
a lot of your arguments seem to be based
on a personal attack of jean-claude
juncker this is on Weis pitch to take
isn't it because he'll be gone fairly
soon rose the effects of brexit will
last forever
let you answer just before I gather some
the answers to those points and others
we want to gradually get you to vote
okay so you should have one of these can
you wave it in the air okay
so just it I know it's almost too
obvious to remind your but a box will
come around if you want to vote for put
four in the box and bin the other one if
you wanna vote against put that in the
box if you're not sure still you're
undecided please put the whole paper in
and then let's let's now have some quiet
if we could to get an answer is about
first of all why the obsession with
Yonker because he's such an easy target
I mean of course he's just one rotten
apple in the basket but I also want to
really nail this people's vote thing
this is a small C piece of spin do not
fall for this this is designed to
repackage a betrayal and a stitch-up
what is a people's boat if we haven't
already had it it was called the
referendum we have had the people's vote
we've done this okay think you just do
deal with your giving signal because
yeah I don't know show you quite address
the gender was a question which is he
would say I think jean-claude juncker is
not the EU there are 27 Democratic
leaders as well as Britain in the EU and
they attempt to characterize everything
the EU does through the words of one man
is misleading only had seven minutes but
I mean if the premise here is that
without John Claude única everything
would be hunky-dory I utterly refute
that and it's worth remembering by the
way that the EU is not a static thing in
fact as Jared said the project evolves
all the time so if we votes to stop this
and go back in again we're binding
ourselves up in even tighten Ulster
general could you to address the
question of capturing markets elsewhere
the tricky things surely for people
making your argument is this answer the
question who does more chip trade with
these other markets Germany or the UK
and last time a lot Germany is not
leaving the EU yeah
well this has been well researched about
how the whole EU structure has been very
favorable to the
an economy and indeed that's why in
Eastern Europe you basically have seen
decimation of the industrial sector why
you've seen basically Dahmer Trump not
that I'm a big fan of many aspects of
Donald Trump he is right on the currency
issue both China and Germany through the
EU have run undervalued currencies
I think the Britain needs to have a much
cheaper currency in terms of the
opportunity I go to China a lot it's
often seen that at the first stage of
the government in China up to now it's
been very much German exports investment
capital goods the next stage of the
government in China it's very much about
British business professional financial
and other services so there is a big
opportunity but it's not just about the
globe opportunity we've got to actually
get the domestic economy right and we
need to have more investments more
infrastructure it's basically lots of
things we should have done that we can't
blame the EU for as Jeff has said but
lots of things we will have new
empowered skills to do and it takes time
ok it really is time to move to the
summit folks some up speeches but in a
sense and I know there's a real appetite
to talk you've got about 20 seconds each
if the microphones with you lucky you if
it's not later on my apologies I know
there are other points that you'd like
to make but there isn't time so let's
just move around them number one first
of all thank you and is there any risk
of economic loss decade similar to Japan
in the 1990s for UK while we attempt to
negotiate for new trade agreements with
with with other countries a loss record
like Japan yeah and well sorry what
other impact is for such scenario of
this kind thank you thank you for your
question number four and would you not
agree that the brexit vote highlights
the fault in our voting system and that
rather than focusing on a vote that's
already happened that we should work to
improve our electoral systems in order
for this not to happen again thank you
number three the narrative of fear is
not working Gina and Chaka why don't you
change your approach okay and finally
there's a lady at the back with the
microphone is that oh that was you I'd
apologize number three no you've got one
okay Legend open that's it for the
public debate I'm afraid and questions
and answers thank you very much instead
of you addressing these individual
you've got a couple of minutes each to
sum up and if there's any of those
points that you want to draw on please
would you do that so we're gonna go in
reverse order from the speeches in the
debate itself and I'm going to start by
reminding you please vote in those boxes
we'll give you the voters soon as we can
and I'm gonna start the wind-up speeches
by asking Gerald lines it's just a
couple of minutes if you would Jared to
give your wind-up speech and you can
just sit where you are that's fine thank
you well thanks to everyone for coming I
think we should embrace democracy and I
think we should embrace the results of
the referendum Chuck I mentioned he had
parents of different nationalities I
mentioned this because of the second
question I have Irish parents dropping
Kilburn
I'm pro-europe the anti-eu in fact unpro
global I think we have enough ability to
address many issues globally and what's
remarkable is the only and I do mean the
only EU country out of 28 that meets its
global commitments is Britain in terms
of spending two percent of its GDP on
defense and spending 0.7 percent on
overseas aid others talk it we do it
it's not easy to leave something you've
been in for 40 years I call it a Nike
swoosh I was fully supportive of brexit
I said relative to what it would
otherwise be the economy in the cover
years after we've left we'll go through
a difficult time you can't be in
something which is so complex
infiltrates our economy so much and
expect it to be easy but it will be
positive if we have the right attitude
we need to get our domestic economy
rights we need to have a good
relationship with the EU we need to
position ourselves believe it's about
basically accepting that good news is
that we're distancing ourselves from a
political project whose economic
underpinnings are flawed jerilyn we have
to address the opportunity outside
Thank You general a couple of minutes
view I think we put too much focus on
our membership of the EU just being
about trade and economics it's also
about security it's about us being able
to be stronger together in so many ways
it is but I want to get to this idea
that I pick up on something Isabelle
said we did we couldn't possibly know
the detail isn't that the point that is
the point we're not let's not revisit
all these old arguments about with the
bus and everything can we just not look
forwards and think this government
whatever it is mrs. May might pull a
white rabbit out of the hat we have to
wait and see if not whatever the deal is
our my view is from talking to everyone
I've met in the EU because of the time
constraints of seven months that we will
be offered a Canada style deal if that
is possible then that should surely go
back to the people when you buy a house
do you not do your searches and your
surveys and your reports and then decide
if you will go ahead rather than getting
something back which is not what you
thought and then you go ahead anyway it
is just common sense
and I wanted and I wanted to answer the
lady at the top we've talked about
fearful messaging we know this is not
about fear this is what people are
talking about now this is a detail this
is looking at the government's own
scenario planning in their reports the
ministers are having to put their phones
away and go in and read okay we have to
look at the detail and ask the difficult
questions but be able to listen to the
difficult answers and then give people
the chance to vote Jeanne Miller thank
you very much indeed
Isabelle election in some ways I'm not
actually in fact in many ways I'm not
frightened by the prospect of another
referendum I think the more people are
pressurized and corralled to vote
different ways of the way they voted the
first time round the more their resolve
will be stiffened but there is a problem
that potentially the result of another
effort referendum would be just as close
and narrow again in one way or the other
and then when the hell will this misery
ever end finally I want to say something
about the tone of this debate I have
felt at times tonight that it has been a
little prickly to say the best now I
mean Gina knows of all people Gina knows
how nasty this debate has become she has
to have security around her which is
just unbelievable I get the fact that
people feel passionately about this but
do we really want to put ourselves
through all this again just to get the
same result no let's crack on
I think I think to me I think to be fair
for Isabel you said he has been forcing
off the end of the centuries which was
to get to the same results
yeah there well but there is clearly
some people who do and as journalists we
just can't wait because it's it's it's
just so much farther at the moment I'm
fine 30:41 not speeches chuckerman three
quick points one in answer to the
question at the top about our electoral
system regardless of brexit I'd like to
see us change it I'd like a system of
proportional representation get rid of
this thing first I suppose secondly that
you don't resolve divisions and dispute
by muzzling debate you have got to have
a discussion and a dialogue that is the
point of democracy which is why I don't
think we should run scared from having a
people's boat so but let me just then go
to the heart of the matter because I
think taking back control is at the
heart of so much of this debate and I
have to say in many respects the biggest
threat to people's individual
sovereignty and the sovereignty of
nation-states are often large
multinational companies which are more
powerful and sometimes have a net worth
more than some countries just look at
all these stories around Cambridge
analytic ah
Facebook and the rest if we want to deal
with that and marshal this international
system to serve people and not the other
way around I don't see how you do that
other than working across borders with
other countries which is why Google sits
up and pays attention when they get a
2.2 billion euro fine from the European
Commission through trying to rig the
global international online marketplace
it is why Apple has been forced to pay
back 10 billion euros in tax that it
thought it could get off having to pay
the Irish government the point is if we
want to get this system to work better
for people a system that operates across
ball
borders democracy has to operate across
borders and we do that with other
countries who have the same values and
the same challenges as us that is why I
want us to stay in the European Union
[Music]
in fact ladies Embry's almost almost the
end of our debate but there are still
squirrels behind the scenes counting
your votes and through the marvelous new
technology I haven't quite yet got a
piece of paper in front of me so I want
to do two things if I may I want to ask
the panel to think of one point you
don't think he's often raised here that
you want people to go away and think of
one last thing for somebody doesn't
agree with you that you would like them
to go away and give some thought to
doing about 30 things there a minute if
you would but take these ladies over I
also don't like to ask you something
which is not the motion tonight but a
more general thing now you are self
selecting you've come to a debates on
brexit can I ask you to if you came here
thinking you were broadly a remainer
could you put your hand up just broadly
and put your hands down oh no keep them
up if you wouldn't mind okay put your
hand down put your hand down
if you only follow people who agree with
you on social media
okay that was about half lives even if
you're a leaver would you put your hands
up put your hands down you know the
punch line now if you only follow people
on social media who are levers fewer to
start with so a little plea from me is
I've said one thing everybody should go
and consider when you get home go and
follow somebody you don't agree with
and if you engage with them engage with
them not my telling them they're idiots
by telling them something you found
quite interesting about what they had to
say so just while we get to find a
result then I'm going to pop back to
each of our panel saying you're not
making argument you don't make doing a
debating point what thing that you've
heard in this debate or in recent months
just as got you thinking very quickly if
you would is about what I would like to
think I would like people to think about
just how ridiculous we will look if we
reverse all of this and just how
disempowered we will be within the EU
what chance will we have of changing
anything within the EU when we behave
like this lovely Gina I've learnt and I
didn't know that 35,000 of our nurses or
people who work in the NHS have
qualifications from the EU that come
over because of the services they
recognize their qualifications are
recognised so they can just come and
work here that will end in the future
okay I also sorry I didn't also know
that there are 35,000 nurses who
actually be retiring so we've got to the
same time there will be a massive
shortage of staff in the NHS Thank You
gerald yeah it's a London audience and
earlier this year the European
Commission produced their analysis of
the 263 regions of the European Union in
terms of competitiveness three of the
top five are in the South of England for
the top ten are in the South of England
that's impressive but Britain has the
most in the Commission's words
heterogeneous group of regions Northern
Ireland West Wales and the valleys
calmer and the City Isles and South
Yorkshire all lagging it's about time
people in London started to think about
the country and about how we reposition
our country globally London has a lot to
offer but I think the European
Commission may be threw down the
gauntlet think about the regional issues
here at home that's great thought [ __ ]
[Applause]
one of the things that has happened
since the levo is the net migration from
the EU has fallen quite significantly
and one of the things I invite people
just to reflect on and particularly in
labour areas that voted to leave there's
no getting away from it immigration was
the big issue in 2016 and if we're
honest about it we haven't really talked
about it so much in this debate but
people were told if that immigration
falls it's going to be easier to get a
doctor's appointment easier to get your
child into school easier to get a job
easier to get a better paid job net
immigration from the EU has fallen all
those things have generally got worse
since 2016 so don't think that if we see
a reduction in immigration from the
European Union or anywhere else it is
going to solve all our problems they're
just the four guys for domestic
politicians not doing what you pay them
to do
[Applause]
[Music]
they drove through the magic of high
technology Mark Zuckerberg eat your
heart out I have a piece of paper just
for my before the votes 65% of people
voted for the motion the brexit should
be stopped 23% were against 12 percent
were undecided after the debates that
figure was I've always wanted to do a
game show 84% for the most 12 percent
against 4 percent undecided
[Music]
so
[Music]
it just remains for me to thank you for
coming to thank you for your
contributions in your debate the can we
thank Chuck Ramona Isabel Oakshott Gina
Miller and Gerald line
finally late snugglin this was a debate
which is a model for what debate should
be thoughtful intelligent civilized
thank you to intelligence squared safe
journey
[Applause]